among the Yuba people an ethnic group of
some 52 million spread between Nigeria
Togo and Benin one of the most
flattering ways to describe a person is
to say that they have much
itutu the word denotes a particular
approach to life unhurried composed
assured and
unflappable if a bus is late a person of
itutu won't shout or get in a dispute
with a ticket vendor they'll let out a
minor sigh and pull a weary smile if the
sky open just when they've laid out
chairs in the garden for a party they
will in their normal tranquil and
unaffected way simply take them all back
in again there isn't much that should
rattle a person of
itutu crucially itutu isn't any sort of
divine gift or chance trait it's a
quality that can be cultivated and is
the outcome of having absorbed a
particular view of existence for the
Yuba agitation and anger flow from a
mistaken and overambitious sense of what
it lies in our power to alter it's when
we believe that we are more in command
of external reality than we actually are
that we respond to reversals and
frustrations with rage the calm person
of itutu may be every bit as sad as
their hysterical counterpart about the
delayed BS or torrential rain shower but
what underpins their equinity is a sense
that trouble could not be skirted and
must be accepted as belonging to the
order of things in their Noble
resignation a person of itutu displays a
grasp of another key term in Yuba
philosophy aay which we might translate
as Destiny existence or the cosmic order
what lies in the province of assay can't
be altered by any human will but an
enlightened person should understand the
direction of assay and then adjust their
desires and Ambitions
accordingly there is one important
detail here itutu doesn't only render a
person wise it additionally makes them
attractive including physically
attractive and what we might call cool
which is why any self-respecting young
Yuba will strive hard to adopt its
outward signs particularly when a
distinguished local photographer like
rashidi bisu has offered to take one's
portrait many cultures retain a
lingering suspicion that being effective
might rely on a capacity to be frantic
and hot-tempered for the Yuba agitation
isn't merely an offense to a proper
understanding of the universe it's also
just horribly
unfashionable